Кому пандемія, а кому - мати рідна. В Україні, яка ледь не щодня
б'є коронавірусні антирекорди, процвітає торгівля "ковідними" довідками.
В Інтернеті - безліч сайтів, які пропонують фальшиві медичні сертифікати
на будь-який випадок - оформлення лікарняного, звільнення від фізкультури,
участь у марафоні, результати флюорографії, висновки нарколога та психіатра.
Продають навіть довідки про вагітність.
А тепер до цього списку додалися фейкових результати тестів на коронавірус,
необхідні зокрема для подорожей за кордон.
Свої послуги зловмисники рекламують як щось цілком нормальне -
навіть публікують відгуки вдячних клієнтів.
Аби з'ясувати, як виглядають липові довідки про тестування на коронавірус,
заповнюємо форму зворотного зв'язку на одному із сайтів -
на вигадане ім'я. Вже за хвилину нам передзвонюють.
-Алло.
- Я телефоную з приводу Вашої заявочки, яку Ви залишили у нас на сайті -
результати тестування ПЛР на Covid-19.
Ми можемо Вам зробити чотири види довідок: швидкий тест,
ПЛР-тест, що наполовину англійською, 209-ту форму різними мовами.
У ній просто не буде зазначено, яким чином зроблено тест.
Просто буде написано - "результат негативний".
Зупиняюся на тесті ПЛР.
- Вам негативний чи позитивний результат?
- DW: Негативний.
- Я зрозумів. Бланк державний, печатка стоятиме,
буде зазначено - "номер дослідження", "дослідний матеріал",
не виявлено РНК до вірусу"
та референтні значення - "Not detected, negativ" англійською.
Яку дату проходження вказати?
- DW: Давайте 7-ме квітня.
- Добре. Дата буде 7-ме квітня.
DW: Проблем із визнанням не було - принаймні тут, у нас?
- Ну, ніби ні. Серйозні фірми подавали.
Позитивний результат, негативний - немає різниці.
Та й сама форма нині, державна - її лише зараз запровадили,
виходить, із додаванням англійської. Тому її якби
вже більше поважають - чисто через це.
Фальшиву довідку нам відправили "Новою Поштою".
За підробку на бланку однієї з київських лабораторій
сплачуємо майже 600 гривень. Справжні тести ПЛР - дорожчі.
Ціни на них починаються приблизно від восьмисот гривень.
Час оформлення довідки - 10:55 7-го квітня.
Тобто отримали ми її за пів години до зазначеного часу видачі.
Така собі машина часу.
Телефонуємо у київську лабораторію, яка нібито робила тест.
- За квітень у нас немає ніяких даних.
Ви спитайте в тій клініці, де Ви здавали, бо у нас немає такого.
- DW: Немає за квітень даних?
- Ні. У нас Ви не здавали нічого за квітень.
Висилаємо фото довідки для порівняння. Відповідь - лаконічна.
Скільки таких ковід-довідок щодня підробляють в Україні,
можна лише здогадуватися. За оцінками комерційного директора
лабораторії "Сінево" - від декількох сотень до тисячі на день.
Так, це реально схоже на справжній результат.
Можливо, є якісь зауваження щодо дрібниць, але в цілому - так,
це схоже на справжній результат. Тобто всередині країни, я думаю,
він абсолютно спокійно буде прийматися всіма.
У деяких країнах, де не так жорстко ставляться до контролю,
я думаю, що він теж цілком може пройти.
Але якщо ми говоримо, приміром, про подорож до Єгипту, де є вимога QR-коду,
то, звісно, він не пройде, тому що тут відсутній QR-код.
Микола Скавронський розповідає, що з підробками стикалася
і лабораторія, яку він представляє.
Щоправда, не масово - адже свої довідки медичний заклад намагається захистити
принаймні шляхом використання якісного паперу та QR-кодів.
Такі коди ведуть до особистого онлайн-кабінету
з підтвердженням проходження аналізу.
За словами Миколи Скавронського, продавці фейкових довідок
про тестування на коронавірус дискредитують не лише лабораторії,
бланки яких вони підробляють. Такі підробки шкодять репутації країни в цілому -
адже купують їх часто саме для подорожей.
Найголовніший і найбільший ризик для України насамперед іміджевий.
Ми можемо потрапити у ситуацію, коли інші країни
можуть просто відмовитися приймати результати українських лабораторій -
немає значення, приватних чи державних.
Це означатиме додаткові витрати для подорожуючих українців.
Вони будуть змушені перездавати тести за кордоном - повірте,
це набагато дорожче. І, я думаю, коли ми вже наблизимося до паспортів вакцинації,
то на ринку може з'явитися і ця пропозиція і, відповідно,
так само не буде довіри з боку інших країн.
У поліції запевняють, що знають про проблему та активно з нею борються.
За даними пресофіцерки Національної поліції Мар'яни Реви,
за фактами підроблення ковід-довідок станом на кінець березня
було зареєстровано 23 кримінальних провадження.
Якщо ми говоримо про підроблювачів, то на них чекає
кримінальна відповідальність відповідно до статті 358
Кримінального Кодексу України. Там передбачена відповідальність
від штрафу до 17 тисяч гривень до п'яти років позбавлення волі.
Для людини, яка використовує підроблену довідку,
також передбачена кримінальна відповідальність -
від штрафу 850 гривень до двох років обмеження волі.
Інформацію про підроблений результат тесту на коронавірус,
який ми придбали в інтернеті, прямо на місці передають у кіберполіцію.
Алло. Добрий день. Є хвилинка у Вас?
Дивіться, спілкуємося зараз із журналістами Deutsche Welle.
Дуже цікава тема. Наша улюблена - підроблені довідки на Covid-19.
З Вашого дозволу я сфотографую і надішлю.
Боротися із торгівлею підробленими довідками в Інтернеті -
вкрай важко, визнають у поліції. Замість одного заблокованого сайту
зловмисників одразу можуть виникнути два-три нових.
Тим часом представники лабораторій, з якими спілкувалися журналісти DW,
кажуть, що комплексно розв'язати проблему
можна було б шляхом створення єдиної бази даних,
куди б усі медичні заклади передавали результати тестів.